enquiries of gentlemen with Channing
Tatum
hey we're in the middle of a GQ fitting
fitting that would be fitting for GQ GQ
hey Jim hey yeah my fuzzy you said I
could have some of this huh one say you
can one thing just these I don't think
you're gonna wear those I'm gonna start
a new trend let's talk about this
tomorrow
well you guys good you guys are good
let's about the shoot tomorrow okay okay
okay all right just say one thing right
I know yeah no just these okay okay I'm
there down there down okay here we go
what's the first thing you reach for in
the morning baby monitor favorite
breakfast to scram B's the kids are
making fun of your name growing up yes
all the time what they call you they
call me Tatum Tatum Pole Tatum top Tater
Tot tittles I don't know superpower
you'd most like to have time I'd like to
be more more time man okay Alabama or
Auburn okay on the Rope had Jonah Hill's
worst habit being [ __ ] funny Oh what
do you and Jonah do to kill time on set
uh-huh we play fifa
what is Donald ducking down duck against
wind generally you got out go out and
get really hammered and then you end up
waking up in the morning and you only
have a shirt on with boots have you ever
been Donald Duck
you don't Donald Duck other people you
don't look yourself have you done I'll
duck yourself of course I have female
fashion thing you really don't get
everything who'd you meet only because
you feel like you should [ __ ]
broccoli man [ __ ] broccoli last thing
you really laughed at Jim Nelson's
[ __ ] face when he realizes that you
[ __ ] pay for all this [ __ ] window
cedar aisle Oh
forever you have been watching enquiries
of gentlemen start the [ __ ] car
start the car start the car with
Channing
you